The one that jumps out at me as frown,
frown,
checking Valerie Piper,
Germany in the 70s.
He play in the NASL for the cosmos.
I think he played for the cosmos.
You know,
I don't know.
I should know my history better than
that,
but,
uh,
he's just an amazing player.
He's very graceful.
Uh,
his decision making was always,
you know,
very clever and,
um,
you know,
and the way he led was,
I,
you know,
I can't say say behind the scenes,
but just in terms of on the field,
he's always projected a cool and
calmness and this composure that I
thought permeated through the rest of
the team.
And I think that's,
uh,
something that I try to emulate in some
regard.
Uh,
you know,
when things are getting tough and things
are hard,
I may try to just try to find that
balance of trying to bring it back the
other way.
And,
and if guys I don't think are doing
enough,
then you know,
I can be that guy too.
And I think that's been the hardest
thing for me because that goes against
my grain is being this other guy.
Uh,
I have in me,
but I never really bring out that much
because I just,
that's not really the guy I choose to
be.
Yeah.